now we're all here to celebrate you
fierce women and the characters you play
both on television and film I'm curious
for the parts you're currently in or
just recently wrapped what is the
kickass moment you're most proud of I
think it's the moment when I finished
killing my ninth German on the beach
just recently with a double sword move
that was a moment or two soon Connie too
soon we we just recently wrapped season
three and we're just starting season
four but I think for me as agent May it
was when these three big guys think that
they were gonna like kind of manhandle
her and she beats the crap out of all
three of them and at the end she says
you know what I'm gonna do your favor
and not tell anyone that a little tiny
Asian woman just kicked your ass it was
a badass moment well I would say thank
you shooting Deadpool was awesome for
many reasons thank you
but I do particularly like the fact that
when she does Vanessa does get rescued
by Deadpool or he's trying to rescue her
instead of being appreciative she calls
him an a-hole
for leaving her to begin with every day
for you right I mean personally or or as
a character I I'm I was pretty proud of
myself that I got through getting
punched in the face pretty hard by a
woman who's like black belt in jujitsu
and that it did make it onto the show I
thought
that's funny that I'm sorry I'm sorry
but we're asking whether personally or
professionally I was like oh yeah
personally popping two babies out of my
well yes that's way cool Wow
so this oh hi guys so this season of
Game of Thrones from a Sunday was quite
interesting um I think my kind of badass
moment was kind of telling Tyrion about
himself when he thought he know he knew
about slavery I'm like no dude you know
nothing so I thought that was kind of a
badass moment I think he likes to talk
and thinks he knows everything he thinks
you know he drinks and he knows things
but he doesn't know everything asthma
Sunday very pointedly told him that was
kind of cool I think my kick-ass moment
first Sara the character I play who's a
sort of English con artist was this past
season when she kind of goes off the
rails and has her night of her dark
night of the soul and sort of reclaims a
part of her identity that she had lost
because of this sort of clone conspiracy
thing that she's been following for her
the past you know a few months of her
life and she sort of reclaims a little
bit of her own space and makes mistakes
and kind of acts like in an [ __ ] and
sort of you know just is Sara and that I
think is the the kick-ass moment from
this past season for me so I I was
thinking what the heck could be my most
kick-ass moment I think it was when I
was being hit on by the Six Million
Dollar Man you know Lee Majors plays
Ash's dad Brock and ash versus evil did
and I Jam my fingers up his nostrils I
wonder if I threw him across the room
but that would be a lie anyway it was
fun to jam my fingers up his nostril
did you ad-lib that or is that scripted
I did kind of ad-lib it and Lee was
young yeah it was fine to go with that
he's very cool guy it's super funny in
the role what's the craziest thing
you've been asked to wear during a fight
scene bucket of snot what anyone else I
mean they think it went addictive of
what I'm wearing in in in these fight
scenes but nobody knows how hard it is
to move in these entire armors I mean
they're really really difficult I have
new respect for people who play Batman
Superman and so on because it is so hard
to move in these things and yet you have
to look at let ik yeah for me it's not
the weirdest thing but the hardest thing
is fighting and heels always just
fighting and running and kicking in high
heels I always wish I was um you know a
little bit taller but since I'm not I
had to adjust that but either that and
actually I I loved fighting in my
lingerie I that was the when I read it
in the script I was so terrified that I
had to fight in lingerie but it was the
best thing because I was bear that that
outfit in Deadpool was not particularly
made for fighting and there with all the
it was all open and we had to and I was
falling from high angles that the crew
saw a lot more of me than they wanted to
not fun now we have a feature in our
magazine called watch this sorry about
that
and we obviously are all watching the
current roles you're in and we're loving
them but to each of you have any parts
from your past that you kind of just
wish you didn't do maybe you wanted to
say sorry for them I didn't mean that
or oops you mean the stuff we do to pay
the rent perhaps yeah no I wouldn't talk
about that here
hahaha why would we bring attention to
them you've moved so far beyond it yeah
well I mean I think you know a lot of
people don't realize that sometimes you
know it's feast or famine as an actor
and especially as with women part and
when women parts with roles for women
sometimes they're very very limited
listen English is my second language but
it's so there are a lot of times when
our decisions to get work is not based
on artistic choices or you know we just
want to get a job so we can pay the rent
so eventually when you don't have any
babies right and you think nobody's ever
gonna hire me again that's right so you
take a show with the title that has
three exclamation marks at the end
that's a giveaway by the way and you
think it's working title if it's named
as vampire bats it's not a working title
that's the title you're gonna be in or
you just want to make enough money to
cover your union minimum so you keep
your insurance so they're you know
sometimes we make those choices and and
and for me I I really don't apologize or
say that I regret having done any of my
roles because it is part of what it
takes to be an actress is to survive it
is to go through the famine and be able
to then celebrate like we are today you
know with these amazing women at this
panel when we are able to you know do
parts that inspire or you know give joy
to our audience and our fans has anyone
else at this table been on Law & Order
I have been on Law & Order SVU you know
I am the only actor in the world who's
never done Law & Order you're not the
only one there might be an actor who
like grew up in New York City and never
been alone I never could get the job I
had a great time on Law & Order actually
and it's not just like surviving but you
learn from every experience and I I did
an episode of CIOs view where I played a
semi lesbian ballet dancer who killed
someone with a statue of a piano loved
that her leg warmer as like a mace kind
of thing I had I had done theater so
much and I really learned the ropes of
working on television and in front of a
camera from jobs like that I actually
have to say I take my hat off to the
people on SVU I mean I stepped in for
Mariska Hargitay for six episodes and my
goodness I we worked so hard and I
remember being like in up in Queens
somewhere or the Bronx I mean somewhere
really far away from where I live and
and and it was 6:30 in the morning on
Sunday morning and we had worked by this
time 18 hours and I was kicking some
poor actors ass in like some alley and
while people were getting up and and I
just I remember I felt like I have never
been this tired in my life and that I
mean just that work I think of the
people who go to work and do this every
day and and do it like exceptionally
well - I really take my hat off
amazing amazing people so fans are
fantastic and they're responsible for
the success of these shows and movies
but I wonder if you could think back and
tell us about just your most unusual fan
encounter something that just stands out
for maybe getting a little weird or
something I remember
I was in a store buying some stuff and
might have been a Walmart because this
big black dude came up to me and he's
like ah I mean ah when oh man I loved I
loved you in that movie and I'm thinking
okay is either chun-li for Street
Fighter or you know just one of those
like action movies and instead he said
you were so good and Joy Luck Club and
that was it made me realize that you
know you just cannot judge anyone by
what they look like you know what they
love and what what they what gets them
going that to me I will never forget it
it was just such a wonderful moment and
we had a great laugh and you know just
ended up talking for like 15 minutes so
that was a great encounter that's great
I once had a fan write to me from prison
asking for me to send a pair of
underwear that I'd been wearing yeah
that was strange and that's probably the
way I mean you said the strangest so
this is definitely there are a lot of
really sweet fans as we can tell by the
thousands of people in this room but um
during V um we would get a lot of fan
mail and I received a beautiful envelope
and letter for that it was addressed to
me but had different separate envelopes
everybody in the cast and they're all
really loving letters and gushing
letters and we all read them or like oh
that's nice and then he said that he was
a confectioner and he he owned a cookie
store and he would make all different
kinds of cookies and he included
photographs of the cookies and it was
like a gingerbread house and like a
strawberry sure
Shem like all these like beautiful
buildings and then the last one was and
he labeled them in the back I looked at
this and I was like that can't possibly
be what I think it is and I look on the
back and it's like chocolate peanut
butter penis with the rest of the stuff
that he made I guess I haven't I haven't
really had many unusual experiences yet
but I did get to meet these Girl Scouts
that they came to sent and they had just
been to the White House kind of making
they're amazing girls and they make
these inventions and they've won this
National Science Fair and they got to
meet Obama and give up their sign
presentation to the President and so if
they met me right after I was old hat to
them and I had my dog on set with me and
they would they were very enthusiastic
about the dog it didn't matter that
there was a person in a cape have you
all been mistaken for anyone else
someone else famous yep any Asian
actress ever out there and even famous
Olympic ice skaters I'm just saying I've
gotten Ashley Judd which is very
complimented by that but what was the
back-up plan if this career didn't work
out was there a back-up plan ever no
this was it
Wow yeah that's what you're all here
what was your backup plan I don't know
what my back-up plan would have been
I thought I've thought about that even
now because at the end of the day like
this this industry is not guaranteed and
it's you know not forever and I thought
what would happen if I you know stopped
working as an actress what would I do
Anna I thought maybe I'd like be a yoga
teacher really like yoga oh and actually
I'm quite enthusiastic about tea so I
thought I would maybe open a tea shop
maybe you could do both I could do both
a tea shop yokas oh that sounds great
thank you I just remember my mom you
know when when I wanted to actually go
to college and study acting and I was
looking at various colleges and to see
which one had the best program and
luckily where I grew up at the time
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania has had a great
college program at Carnegie Mellon
University and I just remember my mother
asked the same question as she did
Nicole so because for her that she was
actually astounded to find out that you
can get a degree in drama she was just
always like Oh American school is so
easy so I've told her that now I've been
a doctor I've been a senator I've been
an FBI agent and you know now yeah now
I'm you know agents that save lives
so as the cavalry she takes all the
credit now so so we've been doing this
panel for five or six years now and
we've never had a shortage of strong
female women to bring up on stage but I
wonder how things are out there are
things getting better
are you still sifting through a lot
of really weak girlfriend wife parts to
get to something good or do you feel
like things have improved I feel like
we're very politicized right now I feel
like the presence of women on in any you
know on TV or film is very political
at least I kind of feel that way I feel
like I watch things with a real critical
eye right now and I'm very aware of the
kind of ramifications of our presence
alone do you know what I mean that
there's a that whether our role is is
empowering or whether it's unempowered
that there's a real pressure on those on
those things to be upheld you know that
that because we're at such an a
politicized time where there's so much
change happening right now there's so
much influence in terms of like what
what we do has a bizarrely huge
influence on how young women see their
future what they have they define
themselves and yeah I just feel like at
least there's a an awareness and I feel
like there's a regardless of whether the
parts are changing I think they are I
think because of things like transparent
because of Jill Soloway because of Lena
Dunham you know these people who come up
and have such a strong voice in such a
strong vision for different kinds kinds
of femininity for different kinds of
gender expression like it's just I think
it we're opening up in a big way but
it's there's also a lot of criticism
there's a lot of you know backlash and
all of that yeah so I don't know if the
rolls are getting better or worse or
whatever but I think there's a neat neat
that's terrible work there's a very
exciting change happening right now
whether it's in motion or it's just like
kind of crackling I'm I feel very
excited by it
I feel like we've been here before I
feel like we were in a moment like that
but you know in the 70s and then a
little bit in the 80s and then there was
a big backlash during the 90s and the
arts and I feel that it's nice that
finally now at least we can talk about
it and not feel as if we are like he
said horrible shrews
who are demanding you know the same as
as men and I think that from my
perspective what would be really nice
would be if when we read scripts you
know I used to always you know have
producers tell me oh you know it's a
journalist it's a this and you know
she's a you know astrophysicist and it's
all these things that they say she is
and I always ask well do you see her do
it because if you don't see her do it
it's just it's just you know garniture
it's just decoration I think that
there's so many things that are
unconscious still in scream
screenwriters is mind and in producers
Minds and even in audience Minds is
about what really is it to be a woman
and a man what what values do they these
these things carry with them and until
we really ask why again and again why we
expect one thing or another from a
female or a male character and why we
accept that we still see you know eight
men and then one woman you know as a
lineup you know until we we really ask
why is that acceptable and why isn't
that you want why is it that you don't
want a much more real experience because
the reality is we are all here we're all
here at the same time in these real
numbers and we need to be able to see
that when we talk about who we are you
know something else along those lines
was also is also age with women you know
I feel like it's we're finally getting
to a time where you see more
age-appropriate casting relationships
you know there was a time when all you
were seeing were like 40 50 year-old men
with 20 year-old girls which is fine but
that that was all that you were seeing
in movies and representations and
relationships and that unless you
under the age of 30 or 28 even like you
were seen as like a different girl and
it wasn't about who the character was or
who the woman was it was just about
being young which was did a huge
disservice at the misrepresentation of
what a relationship is actually like and
then if it was reversed if the woman was
never forties and then then it becomes a
story in itself like that abounds the
focus and the issue because it seems so
unacceptable so there it yeah there's
deafening to take on that cowgirl
usually we're getting to the end of this
panel which I'm very sad about but I
wanted to at least get to at least one
question from the audience do we have
people in line hi hi good afternoon
thank you for your hard work and for
your representation of strong women and
for being great role models for our
daughters thank you very much for being
here
thank you so I find that my question is
very relevant to what you've been
discussing women get better and we get
stronger as we age and mature do you
think that real-life women who have
curves hard-won wrinkles and wisdom will
ever have equal representation on TV and
films it's a great question I think that
you you you should look at you know the
Oscars because those are often the women
who are in fact nominated those are plum
roles I think the problem is almost in
the middle you know it's easier like for
the very young and then once you get
past 50 it gets better again you know
you get like that kind of the meaty
roles again and you know I think of Dame
Helen Mirren and I think of you know a
whole bunch of just unbelievable actors
in a ni na and I think that the roles
are there and they and these women also
a Blee you know produce or get great
producing partners and I think that
that's what most women have to
in order to get this kind of material
out there that you want to see I have a
question for Melinda I mean I mean no
one of course it's hard cuz you know you
really embrace your role so sometimes
forget who you are
you know what that happens to me every
day you just ask my caste so how does it
feel to UM represent two iconic badass
woman like you are Milan and you're
Melinda May so how does that feel
you know for me the extreme joy that I
get is when I come to these cons or and
I've been going to more and more is
meeting with the fans who love Mulan who
grew up with Mulan and as well as the
moms who come up to me with their
daughters who had grown up with Mulan
and now their daughters are watching it
and that their their sense of just being
inspired by a Disney female character
who saves the guy and who is independent
and all of that that the the connection
in in having inspired the young girls
with these roles that's like the biggest
perk of being an actress and I I am just
so happy that I continue to be able to
work on these strong female roles like
Melinda may and just you know kind of
kick ass but it's all because but it's
not I love working on these parts but I
just love that you know it gives it
gives the young girls and the older one
and even men just that that other
perspective about what it is that you
can become as a woman so we're gonna
have to wrap up
before I let you all go I'm curious in
your wildest fantasies who is the one
character superhero part that you would
love to play regardless of gender
who's that there one outfit I want to be
Lucy Lawless
I want to be that's her little jerk no I
say to you I want to be you it's a
really hard question there's so many
great roles sort of floating around
mm-hmm I mean I quite like I quite like
that like the Iron Man films because I
feel like there's such a great there's
such a great representation of women and
like I think that they have lots of
there seems to be this issue of like
women in like technology in science
fields and things like that and I think
the idea of like playing some sort of
science whiz that's also kicks butt like
Iron Man would be fun I want to be James
Bond and the Bond girl is ever allowed
in the same movie I'm gonna be a Raphael
from the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle oh
my god
anybody was gonna be Super Mario
but I love my I'm getting to play I'm
loving playing a Kryptonian wearing that
and I love what she stands for I love
her positivity in the hope and the light
that I think she is just intrinsic to
her
you